Now we need to add the buttons for
the slow and fast playback of the audio.
For this we're going to
use two UI buttons.
With the main story board open and
the play sounds view control selected,
let's search for button in the object
library in the bottom right.
Drag that UI button to the document
outline directly under
the horizontal Stack View.
In the attributes inspector remove
the word button underneath the title.
In the image drop down
select the SnailButton.
In the document outline single
click to select this button and
let's rename it to the SnailButton.
Now let's set the RabbitButton
with the same steps.
Drag a UI button under the horizontal
Stack View underneath the SnailButton.
In the attributes inspector for this
button, let's erase the title and for
the image, let's select the Rabbit.
Finally, single click on
this button to select it and
let's change the name to RabbitButton.
That's all it takes to add
buttons into a Stack View.
Next, we'll add the buttons for
Darth Vader and
squirrel sound effects, as well
as another horizontal Stack View.